(Ana speaking Italian)
(Massimo speaking Italian)
(gentle music)
- Welcome to the Academy.
- Thank you.
And I'm honored to be in
front of this conversation.
- You are very welcome.
The Academy deserves to
have people like you,
and I'm really proud to be
a member of the Academy.
Also, because they're open.
They like to have more members worldwide.
That helps everyone.
Because I mean, we see more movies.
- To be part of one of
many points of view,
I think it is an amazing thing.
When you see a movie, you see the movie,
you can't know how much work is behind...
For example, sometime,
you don't know how much digital
stuff is into the movie,
how much makeup...
- But we talk about that.
We talk about that.
(foreign language)
- Can you believe, Ana,
we were together in the
2005, doing "Volver."
- We met there, in "Volver."
- Big maestro, Pedro Almodovar.
We met in "Volver."
I met Penelope Cruz, and
I met Pedro Almodovar.
For me, it was a very intense experience,
and a very beautiful experience.
- I remember when they say,
you say when
their hair up like a acconciatura,
so we were laughing about
the way that you say
the words in Italian.
- For the translation-
- Now we say a acconciatura.
- Actually, for me to be in Spain,
17 years ago I didn't speak Spanish.
I speak less English
actually than I speak now.
The first time I remember that I arrived
with a shirt, clean shirt,
before to do the fitting.
After the fitting,
I was completely sweat
from the excitement.
I'm a fan of Pedro, I'm a fan of Penelope.
Then I become fan of you, for sure,
and friend more than fan.
It was very intense moments
that we share in "Volver,"
especially in the prep,
because Ped...
do you remember the reference
that we speaking about,
actually was all Italian,
with all the reference,
all preference from Anna Magnani-
- Sophia-
- And Sophia Loren.
- You cannot be good if
there is not a teamwork.
It's really important for us,
I mean, to be like a really good team.
We can do it well,
but if the actor or the
actress doesn't do well,
I mean we don't trust it.
We did really great jobs
when we did our job,
and the actor, like wow,
they look like them.
So with Penelope or with
Javier, they look like them.
- I can just add that you say,
two people play with the harmony.
It's like two musicians.
You have to have harmony in the music.
- And bueno, one director.
- Proud to do this job.
Known to do hair, for my case,
It's not like to do my job
and be happy what the job I did,
but to be part of this job.
It's a beautiful thing.
- Use a line on me you've
never road-tested on anyone,
I dare you.
(soft music)
- Will you like to learn how to rumba?
- All right.
- I could never think
about to be here today.
- And I never thought that
I gonna be living in L.A.,
I mean, and working in L.A.
It was a hard, really hard,
but it really, I mean it was worth it.
You start from zero there.
Like I have been working
30 years in Europe,
but you arrive there and nobody knows you.
They make me like to work.
I mean, I'm in the committee.
Now I'm in judging short films.
I mean, I'm really active
with that because I like it.
The difference that there is
when you work with Europe,
Italy, I mean France, UK, I mean,
everyone works another way.
I mean, between heads of departments,
I mean, it's the same or not.
It's just, you need to make that work.
I think it's part of
our job, make that work.
- The most of the people
is easily adapt of any situation.
Our job meets any inconvenience
of weather, of location.
You go to shoot in other country
with a different culture,
a very important element,
that's because when
you go in other country
with another culture,
you are a guest to work there,
and so you must keep-
- Sometimes you're not welcome.
- Yeah, so you can do the circus,
but you have to do with the respect
in the land where you doing that.
- The last movie that I did in
L.A. was "Being the Ricardos"
in the middle of the pandemic,
and the early '40s and '50s.
It was kind of like,
because it's really American,
and then it was like red lips.
I mean, it is like with all the masks
and I was quite like,
"Okay, I gonna do it.
I gonna do it, because it's
the period that I love it."
And I really like it that they accept me,
but you need to work for that.
Of course not easy,
but for a makeup or a hair stylist
that wants to start in that business,
States is the the best place to.
I mean, you have more opportunities
than any other country.
- It's unbelievable how
all the member of the crew,
actually, I know that we
have a different way to work
in Europe than the States, than
maybe France, maybe England.
I met people that remind me
of people that I met already.
In the end, this kind of
job is a very universal.
- It's good to know the
way that people do things.
Like a wig can be done for one hand
in one way or another way.
- Sure.
- I mean,
I think it's good to work with more people
and see different cultures,
different countries.
I like it.
- You're in control, buddy.
- You with the store or something?
- No, I'm not with the store,
but I'm gonna escort you out of it.
- See what happens.
- Yeah.
- What's gonna happen?
Something bad's gonna happen?
- Yeah.
- Hah, outside.
We're going outside.
- Sometimes people ask
me what I need to do
to be there, to doing that,
to do these kind of movies.
You need to love,
I mean you, you need to have the movies
that really love what you are doing.
Things comes to you.
I don't know, it's not that we are lucky.
It's like we work hard
to do well our work,
because we really trust,
and sometimes you're doing something
or you're gonna do something,
and I cannot sleep.
I mean, I'm in bed, thinking
what I gonna do tomorrow?
It's like nonstop.
But, I mean, I love it.
- You say you must love, sure.
But I want to say what I said before,
about to believe in the
beautyness of your dream.
Doesn't mean to believe
in your dream directly,
but just in the light of your dream.
You must feel this job,
you must, to enjoy.
If not, it's become like another job.
You must feel the
happiness when the director
or your people, your team
is happy what you are doing,
or what all we doing.
And you feel happy,
means it is a good scene,
that you like this job.
- Technique is everything.
But even it's kind of nonstop,
because you always are, new products,
and it's good to know,
to see other people.
Even if the result is the same,
sometimes people do things in another way,
and it's good they can.
The day that we stop learning
is the day that I will stop working.
- If, what I can say about
myself, younger myself,
don't change nothing,
(Ana laughing)
don't move nothing.
Do what you did without change.
Because I think all the process need time,
and this process take me where I am today,
and all the experience
and movie that I did.
(tense music)
(foreign language)
- When are we gonna work
together another time?
I'm missing you.
- Oh, hope soon.
In the magic movie,
any movie that we do, anyway,
is a experience of our lives.
- Yes, wherever they take us.
- Thank you Ana, because to
share with this conversation.
- Always it's a pleasure.
- Thank you.
Love you, Massimo.
(upbeat music)